[Musique]
bienvenue Bienvenue
aujourd'hui on va parler manchot
les manchot du Cap que vous voyez ici
dans cette superbe photo
pour le dérouler de la session vite fait
on va parler d'abord évidemment de du
manchot africain dimanche ou du Cap ici
donc de ce que c'est comme espèce etc et
puis après on va parler des actions au
conservation qui sont faites sur cette
espèce et de son état actuel de
conservation ce qui se passe et des
problèmes que l'espèce rencontre parce
qu'évidemment il y en a quelques-uns
donc je vous présente le manchot du Cap
mon choix africain qui est un manchot
qui comme son nom l'indique habite en
Afrique et oui il y a des manchots en
Afrique
et qui se distingue par ici vous avez
une petite coloration un peu rosée là au
dessus de l'oeil et puis il y a une
sorte de cercle un peu blanchâtre sur le
sur le bec mais à part ça il y a pas il
y a pas beaucoup de différence c'est un
manchot c'est noir et blanc celui-là il
est pas bien grand oui j'ai clairement
pas la taille de mon choix empereur donc
on va partir sur plutôt quelque chose
qui fait 30 40 cm de haut pas plus et
malgré sa taille ici est une petite bête
assez féroce mine de rien car tous les
soigneurs animaliers qui ont déjà
travaillé avec du Manchev vous le diront
ce sont des animaux qui gardent leur nid
et qui garde leur petit de manière très
très féroce et le petit bec que vous
voyez là en fait il est particulièrement
dur et il meurt très fort donc si vous
voulez si vous vous approchez trop d'un
manchot et qu'il est pas d'accord faites
gaffe au bec c'est il peut faire très
mal avec ça j'en ai déjà fait
l'expérience c'est pas très agréable
voilà donc ça a pas l'air comme ça ça a
l'air tout gentil on dirait un peu des
grosses peluches mais ça ça reste des
oiseaux qui ont un certain esprit
combatif voilà c'est petit mais c'est
féroce
alors c'est mon jeu du Cap ils vivent
sur la côte sud-africaine et un j'avais
une petite carte
quelque part donc on parlera de cette
carte après mais en gros vous avez ici
l'Afrique du Sud c'est les différentes
provinces et
vous avez le manchot qui va s'installer
ici sur les côtes de l'Afrique du Sud
tout du long jusqu'au Mozambique là-haut
et jusqu'à la Namibie de ce côté là bon
du côté du Mozambique les colonies ont
un peu disparu maintenant mais il y en a
jusqu'à la Namibie donc jusqu'à la côte
jusqu'en haut de la côte ouest ici et
puis après vous en avez autour du Cap là
autour de Port Elizabeth bref ça remonte
un petit peu sur cette côte ici mais bon
ça va pas jusqu'à Durban ça va pas
jusque là ça généralement en ce moment
il va être plus ici voilà dans cette
dans cette zone là et puis et puis c'est
tout
c'est un manchot qui vit dans des
températures qui peuvent être un peu
considérées comme chaude pour un manchot
parce que évidemment on n'est pas
toujours dans la neige ici en Afrique du
Sud en été on peut quand même atteindre
des températures qui sont assez hautes
de l'ordre de 30 35 degrés donc c'est un
oiseau qui est adapté à des climats qui
sont pas trop froids finalement
bien qu'en hiver surtout sur le banc de
mer ça puisse s'appuie se descendre un
petit peu on reste sur un climat au
scène évidemment ce manchot est en voie
de disparition sinon vous en parlerez
pas de ça conservation je sais pas si
vous connaissez un petit peu l'histoire
de l'Afrique du Sud mais en gros il y a
eu toute une période de colonisation 17e
18e siècle avec des colons qui sont
remontés du cap du sud de l'Afrique du
Sud pour remonter ici jusque dans les
terres et ses colons ont utilisé pas mal
de choses sur la sur la côte et
notamment ils ont ils ont vu les
manchots à l'époque ils ont fait des
rapport sur la quantité de manchot qui
avait à l'époque
lorsqu'ils sont arrivés et on parlait de
jusqu'à un million de couples de
manchots sur sur le bord de la de
l'Afrique du Sud
pour vous donner une idée de ce qui
reste actuellement on table entre 10000
et 20000 couples et la quantité de
couple de manchots de
du Cap diminue tous les ans
malheureusement donc voilà on est passé
d'une population de manchot qui était
énorme finalement une population de
manchot qui se restreint d'année en
année alors le manchot du Cap je sais
pas si vous en avez déjà entendu parler
mais je crois que j'en avais j'en avais
parlé une fois dans un épisode du Corée
de la Stern d'ailleurs si vous voulez
aller voir le podcast n'hésitez pas le
courrier de la Stern et on avait parlé
des petits points blancs qu'ils avaient
sur le ventre
qui sont qui sont intéressants parce que
c'est un peu leur carte d'identité pour
un peu comme nous on a nos empreintes
digitales eux ils ont leurs petits
points sur sur le ventre ici qui sont
spécifiques à chaque individu bien que
dans certains cas c'est petits points
peuvent varier en fonction des mues ou
alors lors du passage
du plumage juvénile au plumage plus
adulte voilà mais en gros ça c'est une
manière de reconnaître un manchot parce
qu'ils sont plus ou moins tous
différents et en zoo c'est bien pratique
parce que ça vous permet de savoir qui
est qui parce que si vous regardez juste
la tête du manchon souvent ça va être un
peu compliqué on va dire qui se
ressemblent tous beaucoup cette photo là
a été prise à bullders Beach donc vous
avez pas mal de colonies qui sont sur le
sud de l'Afrique du Sud et notamment
vous avez boules de Beach voilà donc
bouger Beach c'est sur le sud de
l'Afrique du Sud c'est juste à côté du
cap et là vous avez une autre photo ici
de la plage en question c'est souvent
une plage avec pas mal de touristes à
côté et c'est une plage où il y a une
grosse colonie de manchot qui ont été
arrachés suisses suite d'ailleurs à une
action conservation dont on parlera tout
à l'heure donc ces petits manches
longues qui vivent sur la côte sud de
l'Afrique du Sud malheureusement leur
vie n'est pas très simple
parce que ils ont des tas de problèmes
le premier ça a été lorsque les colons
se sont installés en Afrique du Sud ils
ont décidé évidemment pour s'installer
sur les côtes de l'Afrique du Sud qu'ils
allaient aussi commencer à faire de
l'agriculture sauf que lorsque vous
faites de l'agriculture et que vous
intensifiez petit à petit votre
agriculture vous avez besoin de ce qu'on
appelle des engrais et alors à l'époque
il y avait pas vraiment d'engrais de
synthèse on est d'accord on parle 17e
18e siècle voire 19e à cette période là
les engrais de synthèse même si au 20e
19 20e on va dire que ça commence 20e
avant ça non et alors avant ça on
utilisait des fientes d'oiseaux qui
contiennent pas mal de choses qui
permettent qui permettent vraiment à vos
plantes de bien partir alors attention
c'est souvent très concentré vous pouvez
faire ça si vous avez des poules dans le
jardin d'ailleurs si ça vous dit
vous récupérez les fientes et puis vous
l'utilisez pour faire de l'engrais à
diluer cela dit parce que c'est souvent
très concentré à l'époque les fermiers
les colons du coin c'est que ils
allaient sur les îles euh des manchots
donc là vous avez par exemple un
environnement typique de manches ou du
cap sur des sur des rochers d'habitude
ils sont pas sur du sable là vous les
avez ici sur du sable parce que
malheureusement voilà donc là vous les
avez sur du sable parce que bah ils ont
plus trop d'environnement possible mais
on en parlera encore tout à l'heure mais
normalement
l'environnement de base du manchon
sud-africain c'est ça c'est du rocher
voilà c'est avec la mer autour et sur ce
rocher là comme il y passe leur vie ils
font aussi pas mal de fientes dessus et
ils vont accumuler ce qu'on appelle du
guano c'est-à-dire que vous avez couche
après couche de fiente accumulées sur
ses rochers qui vont faire une sorte de
une couche très épaisse qui pouvait
aller jusqu'à plusieurs mètres de haut
et dans lequel ils allaient creuser
notamment leur nid
voilà parce que c'était un peu plus
malléable que les rochers quand même ça
ça permet de creuser
or ce guano donc c'est fiante de
manchots ont été utilisés pendant tout
le 18e et le 19e comme engrais par les
colons qui s'étaient installés en
Afrique du Sud et qui avait bien besoin
de cultiver leur terre donc ceux qui ont
fait c'est qu'ils sont allés sur les
îles des manchots qu'ils ont récupéré
tout le Bono qu'ils ont pu qu'ils ont
quasiment vidé les îles des manchots de
leur guano et des manchots ce sont de
retrouver avec des rochers sans guano
premier problème pour les manchots le
guano ça leur sert à faire leur nid donc
bah sans guano plus ni donc lorsque vous
avez plus de gouano et que vous êtes un
manchot bah vous êtes obligé de faire
comme ça c'est-à-dire de nicher bah en
faisant un petit trou peut-être dans une
plage avec du sable si vous en trouvez
une ou bien et d'aller directement
nicher sur un rocher et
d'être un peu à la merci des prédateurs
parce que la raison pour laquelle les
manchots faisaient des nids en du guano
c'est que lorsque vous êtes sous terre
quand vous êtes un manchot vous êtes
protégé les prédateurs alors j'avais ici
voilà cette petite image par exemple
alors là c'est un nid artificiel parce
que des vrais ni de manchots creusés
dans du guano comme il y avait il y a
quelques centaines d'années de nos jours
il y en a quasiment plus donc ça par
exemple c'est une une image de ni
artificielle qui a été construit pour
remplacer ce qui aurait dû être
l'habitat originelle des manchots du Cap
donc vous voyez ici le manchot là en
l'occurrence il y en a deux c'est un
couple qui va se mettre face à l'entrée
de son nid qu'il a creusé lui-même
normalement et qui va donc le défendre
en se mettant en fait la tête devant le
nid
en présentant juste le bec et en gardant
l'intérêt du corps à l'intérieur le
reste du corps à l'intérieur du nid
comme ça ce qui va lui permettre de bien
protéger son nid en laissant dépasser
uniquement le bec histoire de bien
pouvoir mordre tous les prédateurs qui
essaient de s'attaquer aux poussins ou à
l'oeuf ou ce qu'il a mis dans son nez en
tous les cas
et ça évidemment si vous leur retirez
leur nid le manchot il est plus protégé
du tout donc tous les prédateurs qui
sont autour qui vont essayer de choper
les poussins et ils ont le champ libre
en quelque sorte donc premier problème
pour le manchot on lui a retiré son
goino et du coup il peut plus construire
de nid donc évidemment vous avez un
problème de survie des jeunes qui font
que bah votre population de manchot a du
mal à se maintenir et donc ça ça ne date
pas d'hier vu que ça date des siècles
précédents deuxième problème pour le
manchot et là on va revenir à notre
petite carte précédente te voici
deuxième problème pour le manchot c'est
la nourriture alors la nourriture le
manchot il est pas très difficile il
mange pas mal de petits poissons ça
reste ça reste du piscivore
sauf que ces poissons en ce moment
ils ont tendance à diminuer
je sais pas si vous êtes au courant mais
on a pas mal de surpêche un peu partout
dans le monde et notamment en Afrique du
Sud on a de la surpêche au niveau des
sardines
qu'est-ce qui se passe avec les sardines
en Afrique du Sud bon alors les sardines
ont besoin de courant froid c'est
généralement dans ces eaux là qu'elles
vivent et elles sont très très présentes
en Afrique du Sud dans un courant qui
s'appelle le Benguella qui est là juste
là qui entre 14 et 20 degrés qui est
parfait pour les sardines pour leur vie
donc c'est là qu'elles vont gentiment
sardiner et donc il y a pas mal de
pêcheurs qui utilisent cette zone là
pour aller pêcher des sardines et qui
les pêchent par Horton entière pour les
envoyer dans le monde entier le problème
c'est que non seulement il les pêche ici
dans les eaux où elle reste
la majeure partie de l'année mais il les
pêche aussi en hiver lorsqu'elles vont
se reproduire dans un courant ici qui
est beaucoup plus petit et qui est
beaucoup plus proche des côtes
qui va remonter quasiment jusqu'aux
Mozambique donc jusque là et qui va
passer par tous les grands ports
d'Afrique du Sud ici et donc
qui vont être qui va être
particulièrement utilisés par tous les
pêcheurs parce que c'est à cette là que
les sardines vont se regrouper en grands
bancs de sardines c'est ce qu'on appelle
le sardines run et elles vont non
seulement migrer mais elles vont aussi
se reproduire c'est leur saison de
reproduction l'hiver pour les sardines
c'est à cette période-là normalement que
vous avez tous les grands prédateurs qui
viennent essayer de choper des sardines
aussi parce que c'est la le moment
parfait pour eux pour les dauphins pour
les requins pour les baleines bref pour
tout le monde pour venir se payer une
bonne tranche de sardines mais c'est
aussi le moment rêvé pour tous les
bateaux pour les chalutiers et pour les
autres pour venir aussi choper de la
sardine donc entre tous ces prédateurs
et tous les chalutiers sans compter tous
les gens qui sont sur le bord des côtes
et qui vont de leur petite épuisette
aussi pour récupérer un max de sardines
parce que c'est un courant tellement
proche des côtes qu'en fait quand vous
êtes sur la plage vous pouvez aussi
récupérer des sardines avec votre
épuisette
clairement sans aucun problème et vous
pouvez donc on va faire votre petite
réserve pour l'année si vous avez envie
et donc tout le monde y va de sa petite
épuisette pour aller chercher de la
sardine sauf que le problème c'est que
quand on surpêche pendant cette période
là pendant qu'on est en hiver pendant la
saison de reproduction en fait vous
empêchez du coup certaines sardines de
se reproduire et vous faites diminuer
encore d'autant plus la quantité de
sardines qui va y avoir l'année suivante
qui a eu moins de reproduction donc ce
qui fait que d'année en année ce
sardines run devient de plus en plus
petit et les manchots qui utilisent la
sardine comme l'un des poissons les plus
importants alors alimentation bah ils
ont de moins en moins à manger donc la
quantité de sardines ici que vous avez
généralement à l'année diminue d'année
en année et ça c'est un deuxième
problème pour les manchots parce
qu'évidemment si vous avez pas mangé et
bah il y a pas de survie voilà donc non
seulement ils sont piqués leur nid mais
en plus ils se font piquer leur bouffe
clairement ça se passe pas très bien
l'autre petit problème parce qu'il n'y a
pas que ça non plus évidemment c'est
toujours pareil vous avez les soucis de
réchauffement climatique évidemment donc
bon là on vous donne des températures
indicatives ici pour pour les courants
océaniques mais faut voir que c'est
température ont tendance à changer
dernièrement que là vous avez ce qu'on
appelle lagulasse par exemple qui est un
courant chaud qui descend
qui a tendance en ce moment à faire un
peu n'importe quoi d'ailleurs donc on
sait pas trop comment ça va influencer
les populations de poissons qui sont sur
le côté de l'Afrique du Sud là
en ce moment on est un peu dans le flou
on sait pas comment ça va évoluer dans
les mers au niveau des courants au
niveau des températures au niveau de la
survie du coup et des espèces qui sont
associées à ça on a on est beaucoup dans
le flou et on s'inquiète un petit peu
parce que la survie de ces espèces de
poissons et du coup directement lié à la
survie des espèces comme le manchot
africain
qui évidemment ne pourra pas survivre si
s'il y a pas un ange
voilà donc là on est parti déjà sur du
bon gros problème le réchauffement
climatique l'habitat détruit et le
problème de nourriture donc le Manche du
Cap a de sérieux soucis en ce moment
sans compter évidemment les soucis
éternels de pollution de marée noire qui
a pu avoir il y a déjà quelques années
bon la dernièrement il y en a pas trop
eu heureusement parce que sinon ça
aurait pas été top
mais voilà vous imaginez que le pauvre
il est en train de se prendre sur la
tronche toute une pléthore de problèmes
divers et variés qui sont qui sont un
solvables à son niveau de toute façon et
que si nous on ne fait pas quelque chose
on va bientôt documenter l'extinction de
cette espèce malheureusement est-ce que
cette colonie cohabite avec les humains
donc celle de bouledogs Beach j'imagine
la colonie de boulders Beach donc qui
est juste à côté du Cap cohabite plus ou
moins avec les humains parce que c'est
des manchots qui sont
relâchés d'une opération de conservation
je sais pas si on les voit ici
[Musique]
donc en gros c'est des manchots qui
viennent d'un endroit qu'on appelle
sencobe c'est un centre de sauvegarde
qui est spécialisé dans la sauvegarde
des manchots du Cap enfin spécialisé
jusqu'à un certain point parce que bon
ils font ils font d'autres actions que
lesquelles je suis pas forcément tout à
fait d'accord
pour en parler tout à l'heure si vous
voulez mais bon après on est plus dans
le dans le détail à ce niveau là mais
voilà ceux-là je suis pas je suis pas
très fan mais en gros ce qu'ils font
c'est qui récupère des œufs sur le dans
les nids des manchots faut savoir que
les manchots tous les ans ils pondent un
ou deux œufs chaque couple de manchots
et parfois il faut une deuxième pompe
derrière si la première n'a pas réussi
ou voire même une deuxième des fois si
la première a réussi mais s'il y a
suffisamment de nourriture enfin bref si
toutes les conditions se réunies pour
une deuxième ponte et eux ce qu'ils font
c'est que ils vont récupérer des œufs
dans les nids ils en laissent un souvent
et puis ils récupèrent le deuxième
voilà donc ils vont récupérer un œuf et
il laisse le deuxième sur place pour que
les parents puissent quand même en
élever un et ils élèvent donc le
deuxième poussin à la main et après ce
qu'ils font c'est qu'il relâche le
poussin en question dans l'habitat donc
là on est sur une action de conservation
voilà typiquement bon après je suis pas
super d'accord avec leur méthode
d'élevage de manchots
qui me qui me font un petit gay mais là
c'est plus moi en tant que
que professionnel de l'élevage de Zodio
on va dire mais bon
je t'en projet qui se tient voilà c'est
juste que les manchots qui qui en
sortent je suis pas tout à fait certaine
qu'ils soient vraiment adapté à vivre
dans la nature et c'est c'est la raison
pour laquelle on a cette colonie qui est
si proche de l'homme au final c'est
alors que normalement n'importe quelle
colonie de manchots sauvages je vais
essayer de vivre le plus loin possible
de l'homme
et qui va essayer de vivre dans des
environnements qui sont pas des
environnements avec du sable là
l'environnement que je vous ai montré là
tout à l'heure avec ce sable là c'est
clairement pas l'environnement naturel
du manchot le manchot il vit sur le sur
le rocher il vit sur des endroits où
c'est ses caillouteux ou c'est
ici c'est compliqué d'accès souvent pour
nous d'ailleurs et même pour eux aussi
mais il vit pas sur des plages et il vit
certainement pas au contact de l'homme
donc c'est pour ça que je suis un peu
je suis pas vraiment fan de la manière
dont ils font leur projet je pense qu'il
y a deux trois trucs qui pourraient
améliorer et je trouve que
c'est pas de mon point de vue c'est pas
c'est pas le mieux il y a d'autres il y
a d'autres projets que je trouve un peu
mieux donc tu parleras après mais ouais
ceux-là vivent un peu trop au contact de
l'homme pour moi
ça pose quelques autres soucis derrière
notamment ça va poser des soucis au
niveau des chats des chiens et de tout
ça parce que en fait cette plage est
juste à côté de la ville alors là vous
le voyez pas trop mais la ville elle est
juste là et du coup
tout ce qui est charges qui ont héron
chez à domestique de toute façon qui qui
a envie de passer dans le coin et choper
un poussin sur des nids qui sont pas
protégés ils peuvent tout à fait le
faire et du coup vous relâchez des
manchots ici dans cet endroit là
pour que de toute façon leur succès
reproducteur derrière soi quasiment nuls
vu que leur petit se font bouffer
donc je trouve pas que ce soit très
intéressant
de faire ce genre de choses et d'avoir
des manchots vraiment proches des villes
à cause de tous les soucis qu'on amène
avec nous en tant que humain voilà bon
après oui ça c'est la colonie de manchot
qui vit au contact de l'homme et qui est
bref je pense qu'on a vu un petit peu
tous les problèmes qui peuvent tomber
sur la tête de ses pauvres manchots du
cap il serait peut-être temps de voir si
on a des solutions après tout ça
pourrait quand même être intéressant
alors j'ai participé à plusieurs projets
pour le manchot Sud Afrique notamment
celui-là ce manchot sud-africain non on
a vu qu'il lui manquait une chose
principale il lui manquait de quoi faire
des nids il manque un site de
nidification enfin il lui manque pas les
sites de nidification et les manque
surtout le matériel pour faire les nids
lui manque le guano qu'il avait à
l'origine donc ce qu'on a fait ceci
alors il y a eu plusieurs types de Denis
artificiel qu'on a mis en place et ça
c'est la dernière version voilà déjà
cinq six ans cette dernière version mais
bon elle fonctionne pas mal
c'est un c'est une sorte donc de ni
artificielle deux épaisseurs donc vous
avez le nid à l'intérieur et au dessus
ce qu'on appelle la fly sheet pour des
soucis de de conservation d'hydrométrie
de des soucis de ventilation enfin bref
de conservation de la chaleur aussi
et donc ça c'est un nid qui va permettre
de remplacer les nids originaux dans
lequel les manchots auraient dû protéger
leur petit donc l'avantage c'est que
donc vous allez entrer de ce côté là
voilà donc vous avez ici une petite
image avec un nid
up et une entrée ici donc vous voyez que
c'est la taille du manchon clairement et
ça va permettre au manchot de faire
comme dans ces nids naturels qui
normalement creusé lui-même il va
pouvoir se mettre donc bien face à
l'entrée avec le bec qui ressort et puis
protéger sa progéniture sans problème
contre les prédateurs parce
qu'évidemment on a des petits soucis
aussi sur les îles on pourrait dire
c'est juste des chats et les chiens
errants sur les sur les plages qui sont
embêtant avec les manches handicap mais
en fait c'est pas du tout le cas sur les
îles vous avez aussi tout ce qui est
autre oiseau marin qui viennent choper
les petits dans les nids pendant que les
parents sont partis à la mer pour aller
chercher du poisson
et donc les petits sont laissés sans
surveillance et comme ils sont pas bien
cachés au fond d'un nid ils sont
facilement visibles de haut et notamment
par tout ce qui est goéland
cormoran etc qui viennent sans piquer
une bonne tranche et qui viennent donc
choper les poussins directement dans les
nids qui sont assez ouverts lorsque vous
avez un nid fermé comme ça et vous avez
beaucoup moins de pression de prédation
sur les petits poussins et ça vous
permet d'augmenter votre succès
reproducteurs des couples de manchots ce
qui est pas ce qui est pas négligeable
quand même il y a juste un ou deux
paramètres qu'on avait qu'on a dû
vérifier pour ces ni là comme je disais
il faut faire attention à la température
dans le nid faut que ça dépasse pas une
certaine température il faut que ça pas
en dessous d'une autre température non
plus pour que le petit est pas trop
chaud mais pas trop froid non plus et
puis faut pas non plus que
faut pas non plus qu'il y ait trop ou
pas assez d'humidité parce que c'est
pareil vous allez lorsque vous incubez
un œuf
vous avez
à l'intérieur de l'oeuvre des membranes
qui vont soit se rigidifier soit devenir
très très souple voire même trop souple
des fois et qui vont laisser passer
normalement l'air ambiant mais aussi qui
vont devoir laisser passer le poussin
lorsqu'il va être prêt à éclore et si
elles sont trop rigides ou voire pas du
tout assez rigide l'un comme l'autre ne
vont pas pouvoir traverser la membrane
donc ça va être en mettant et ça va
faire que l'oeuf ne pourra pas éclore
correctement ne pourra pas se développer
correctement donc vous avez tous ces
problèmes là qui sont importants dans la
création des nids aussi et qu'on a dû
qu'on a dû vérifier avant de mettre ça
en route et avant de mettre ça en
production ah c'était les prototypes
Denis qu'on avait fait
ça c'était chouette ça il y avait plein
des différents attendez que je vous
montre ça il y avait un qui était
marrant parce que voilà il y avait de
l'herbe dessus là on avait essayé
celui-là tout cela c'était les nids en
céramique avec le même matériau et on
avait testé plein de formes différentes
parce que la forme aussi une influence
sur
la distribution de l'air à l'intérieur
la quantité d'isolation vous allez
obtenir aussi pour voir si la
température va beaucoup varier en
fonction des températures ambiantes ou
si au contraire vous allez avoir une
bonne isolation qui va permettre d'avoir
une température à l'intérieur qui va
être plus ou moins constante évidemment
il y aura des variations on n'a pas de
on n'a pas d'isolation en polystyrène
là-dedans mais voilà on essaie de garder
une température plus ou moins constante
et une hygrométrie plus ou moins
constante à l'intérieur aussi donc là le
premier minis il était très bien parce
qu'en fait c'était un nid qu'on avait
recouvert avec des plantes locales sur
les îles vous avez une végétation locale
évidemment qui est constitué de deux
petits trucs
assez bas des toutes petites plantes des
petits machins qu'on l'air de rien comme
ça vraiment mais mais qui mais qui mis
ensemble en fait sur un nid comme ça et
puis vous rajoutez un peu quelques
galets des cailloux un peu de terre ce
que vous voulez et ben en fait c'est
vachement isolant c'est un peu le même
effet avec
je sais pas si vous avez vu les trucs
comme ça si les maisons de Hobbit il y a
pas mal de gens comme ça qui font des
maisons avec un toit en terre en fait et
ça une isolation c'est vraiment c'est
pas mal niveau isolation vraiment et
donc c'est ce qu'on avait testé
là-dessus alors c'est pas mal par contre
le problème de ce truc là c'est que sur
les îles cette végétation on aimerait
pas non plus trop l'encourager il en
faut un peu mais faut pas non plus qu'il
y en ait trop parce qu'il faudrait pas
que ça recouvre tout sinon les manchons
pourraient pas nicher
les manchots donc il y a une nicher
entre les rochers dans le guano mais il
n’échent pas dans la végétation
normalement donc en fait ça c'était pas
c'était peut-être pas mal au niveau
au niveau de la température et
d'humidité mais c'était pas top au
niveau environnement naturel pour le
manchot en fait donc il y avait ça aussi
qu'il fallait prendre en compte donc on
n'a pas trop pu utiliser ce design là
mais voilà donc ça vous donne une idée
de tous les trucs en fait qui rentrent
la réflexion derrière pour essayer de
trouver un produit que sur le plus
adapté possible pour votre espace et
c'est vraiment pas simple parce qu'il
faut vraiment prendre en compte tous les
paramètres pour l'espace en question
alors après il y a d'autres d'autres
modèles comme ça celui-là
alors celui là on avait rajouté des
trous pour la ventilation parce qu'on
trouvait qu'en fait
ils avaient essayé celui-là ici et
celui-ci alors on va le faire dans
l'ordre parce que c'est dans celui-là
voilà donc ils avaient essayé celui-là
ou en fait ils avaient mis des ils
avaient remplacé la végétation
uniquement par du caillou et ça avait
pas bien marché du tout la température a
été montée en flèche c'était terrible
vraiment et notamment quand il faisait
quand il faisait chaud que ton avis
c'était plus en coloration un peu plus
blanche pour éviter que ça prenne trop
le soleil mais
on n'avait pas pu non c'était vraiment
terrible au niveau des températures avec
du soleil ce n'est pas possible ils
allaient rôtir dedans les œufs ça c'est
clair
celui là on avait essayé sans les
cailloux bon c'était pareil ça avait pas
changé grand chose pas d'isolation et
puis le cinquième on avait commencé à
rajouter la ventilation donc il y avait
deux trous ici pour la ventilation puis
un ou deux derrière je crois
j'étais un peu mieux mais on avait quand
même grosse hausse de température
lorsqu'on avait beaucoup de soleil
dessus le lit numéro 6 cette fois-ci
c'est là on avait commencé à développer
le concept de flightshit donc c'est la
couche supérieure qui est différencie du
Nick et à l'intérieur donc on a rajouté
une couche
pour en fait avoir cet espace entre les
deux qui permettait d'avoir une couche
d'air un peu comme dans votre doudoune
quand vous mettez une doudoune pendant
l'hiver vous avez des couches de
tissu et puis à l'intérieur vous avez du
duvet des machins ce que vous voulez et
qui va emprisonner de l'air en fait
c'est un moyen d'emprisonner de l'air
comme dans votre oreiller pour que vous
ayez une sorte de d'isolation qui se
fasse donc là c'est un peu le but le but
c'était d'emprisonner de l'air entre
deux couches de trucs donc de laisser à
peu près cet espace là entre les deux et
de rajouter des trous de ventilation en
dessous pour que l'air circulent bien
aussi dans le nid à l'intérieur et ça ça
avait pas mal marché et finalement on
avait gardé cette forme là ici qui
finalement était meilleur au niveau de
la
de la forme parce que ici au bout
le nid il peut pas juste être tout plat
pour les manchons on s'en est rendu
compte après c'est que le manchot il
aime se tenir debout dans son nid de
temps en temps quand même or si vous le
gardez tout plat comme ça il pourra
jamais se tenir debout il sera obligé
d'être toujours allongé et c'est pas
bien pratique pour lui donc ce qui
faisait en dessous de ces ni là quand on
les avait testé avec les manchots c'est
qu'en fait il a les creuser en dessous
du nid en plus pour se faire un an donc
pour se faire un endroit suffisamment
haut pour qu'il puisse se tenir debout
tout en gardant l'entrée suffisamment
vaste pour qu'il puisse se défendre
juste en laissant coucher avec le bec
qui ressort et ça donc c'était la
meilleure solution pour les manchots
parce que quand vous posez ça sur un
endroit où bah il y a pas de terre il y
a pas de gravier il y a juste du rocher
en dessous autre manchot de toute façon
il ne pourra pas creuser donc vous allez
être obligé de lui proposer une forme
qui va
faire en sorte qu'il puisse se lever au
fond du nid s'il a besoin pour aller
ouvrir son petit ou voilà pour retourner
l'oeuf enfin bref n'importe mais du coup
on avait un Nick était comme ça donc
voilà c'était un truc en triangle en
quelque sorte la vie est la partie à
l'arrière le ni lui-même qui était plus
haute que la partie d'entrée qui elle
était beaucoup plus basse pour que il
puisse garder son lit tranquillement
donc il y avait aussi tout ça qui était
rentré là-dedans la création du nid
c'était voilà il y a plein de trucs
auxquels il faut penser auxquels on
pense pas parce qu'on n'est pas on n'est
pas l'espèce en question tu voulais donc
on n'est pas on sait pas donc il a
besoin de base et c'est que la force de
tâtonnement qu'on arrive à savoir ce qui
lui convient alors il y a quelques
vidéos voilà donc là on a les petits
manchots alors ça c'est un donc ça c'est
un projet qu'on avait fait en
collaboration avec les USA notamment
parce qu'ils ont pas mal de de manchots
de population de manchots qui sont
captifs ça s'appelait invest in the nest
donc c'était un Kickstarter pour essayer
de consulter des fonds pour mettre en
place tout ce projet de fabrication de
nids à grande échelle qui ont été
installées sur un endroit qui s'appelle
Bull Island d'ailleurs alors ça c'est
l'environnement naturel des manchots
donc là on est sur la colonie de Island
justement on est sur le bord de l'île
donc pareil c'est au large des côtes
sud-africaines cette fois là donc là
vous voyez qu'on est plus du tout sur le
même type d'environnement vous voyez ici
sur les rochers il y a du guano qui
commence à se re-déposer ce qui est pas
plus mal mais ça a quand même prendre
quelques centaines d'années voir
quelques millénaires avant que on
atteigne une couche de guano suffisante
pour qu'il puisse à nouveau creuser leur
nid dedans donc c'est un c'est un peu un
problème et là sur la même île vous avez
ici des cormorans voilà il y en a un qui
s'envole là qui partagent le même espace
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut absolument
faire en sorte que les nids des manchots
soient bien protégés parce que vous avez
des oiseaux marins ici différents
espèces qui partagent le même endroit
donc faut faire en sorte que tout tout
ça n'est pas forcément accès aux
poussins des autres espèces
voilà donc ça des petits manches ou les
capes ça c'est un petit jeune
alors les petits jeunes ils sont
marrants parce qu'ils sont ils sont tous
le FUS comme ça
c'est très mimi ils ont encore du duvet
par contre il pense fort avec le mec
voilà ça c'est encore plus jeune tout
petit voilà donc là vous avez encore un
petit ici je sais pas si ils vont
montrer un lit ce serait bien
ça c'est un nid à ciel ouvert alors
c'est pas top
voilà donc ça c'est les nids tel qu'on
les a tel qu'on les a fait donc vous
avez ici le nid en dessous il y a
quelques trous d'aération qui vont être
percés après ça c'est quand on les avait
fait ensemble et puis vous avez sur la
feuille fly sheet pour mettre dessus qui
est une couche protectrice
supplémentaire pour venir recouvrir le
tout donc en fait c'est un ni en deux
parties et c'est fait avec des matériaux
recyclables alors on avait fait ça en
céramique
et
en produit en fibres recyclées et ça
permettait vraiment d'avoir un produit
fini qui soit solide mais en même temps
complètement biodégradable et ça j'ai
trouvé ça vachement chouette c'est on
reste vraiment dans une dans une idée
voilà très très recyclage environnement
et tout et franchement dans ce genre de
projet je trouve ça je trouve ça
important à mettre en place aussi de
penser à la suite donc il y a eu
plusieurs types de nids qui avaient été
testé celui-là c'était en fibre de verre
c'était pas top au niveau de la
température et de l'humidité
parce que là là par exemple
là quand vous voyez les les oiseaux
souvent faire ça et ouvre la bouche
comme ça c'est parce qu'en fait ils sont
en train de réguler leur température
aussi ils ont trop chaud souvent et donc
faut faire faut faire gaffe quand vous
choisissez les matériaux pour construire
des nids quand vous faites des actions
comme ça pour pour aider à construire
des nids voilà donc ça c'était le projet
invest
voilà donc ça c'était l'un des projets
de conservation qui avait été mis en
place il y a déjà quelques années et que
continuer pendant je crois que ça
continue toujours mais bon là j'en fais
plus trop partie en ce moment j'ai
d'autres j'ai d'autres projets en cours
mais voilà ils ont ils ont réussi à
mettre sur de la Lunch des centaines de
nids je trouvais ça très sympa comme
comme type de projet parce que c'est un
projet qui fonctionne en plus et sachant
qu'en plus dans chacun des nids je crois
pas qu'on le voit ici mais dans chacun
des nids j'avais mis
un petit capteur qui permettait de
savoir quelle était la température et
l'humidité à l'intérieur des nids et je
faisais du monitoring de loin
à partir d'un serveur que tu es situé à
Johannesburg et ça me permettait de
savoir de faire un peu de recherche sur
voilà la température à l'humidité à
l'intérieur d'un nid de manchot comment
ça marche en fonction de s'il est habité
s'il est pas habité est-ce que voilà
donc voilà tout ça c'est lié aussi avec
de la recherche derrière et c'est
toujours c'est toujours intéressant pour
pouvoir proposer de nouvelles méthodes
pour essayer de protéger de conserver
ces espèces là alors donc on a parlé
d'une deuxième action de conservation
qui concernait
les manchots
de bouledogs donc avec
sencobe ici qui est le centre de
sauvegarde du manchot et de quelques
autres
oiseaux marins aussi et donc acuptown
directement donc voyez ici dans pas mal
de projets
donc ils ont un truc avec des trains de
sponders alors ça c'est un truc qu'on
avait commandé commencé ensemble aussi
ça c'est un projet qui va permettre de
savoir quel manchot son en quelle
colonies parce que vous avez pas qu'une
seule colonie de manchot il montre pas
grand chose
vous avez pas qu'une seule connerie de
manchots en fait quand on reprend cette
carte là vous allez avoir des colonies
de manchot un peu partout donc vous avez
l'avoir des communes manchots ici du
côté du Cap vous allez avoir des
vraiment chaud du côté de Port Elizabeth
vous allez remonter jusqu'à islanden et
puis vous allez remonter de ce côté là
jusqu'en Namibie où il y a aussi
quelques colonies de manchots et alors
ce qu'on ce dont on s'est aperçu c'est
que ces colonies de manchots elles ne
sont pas fixées c'est-à-dire que vous
pouvez avoir des manchots qui vont se
balader d'une colonie à l'autre
généralement quand ils sont plus jeunes
parce que c'est dans cette période là
qui vont essayer de trouver un endroit
où s'établit en quelque sorte fonder une
famille etc et donc ils vont passer
d'une colonie à l'autre en essayant de
trouver un coin à accueillant ou épices
s'installer ça leur plaît alors on sait
pas trop comment est-ce qu'il détermine
le coin qui leur plaît mais en gros il
passe voilà d'une colonie à l'autre en
disant moi je vais aller là moi je vais
aller là moi je vais aller n'importe et
qu'on aimerait quand même savoir
derrière c'est d'une comment est-ce
qu'il détermine la colonie dans laquelle
ils vont ça peut être intéressant à
savoir et de deux jusqu'où ils vont on
sait qu'il y a des individus qui passent
une colonie à l'autre mais on ne sait
pas d'où est-ce qu'ils viennent on ne
sait pas jusqu'où ils enfin bref on
connaît pas beaucoup leur migration
répartition on aimerait on aimerait en
savoir plus donc le but de ce petit
programme c'était de mettre dans les
dans les manchots une sorte de petite
puce un peu comme lorsque vous poussiez
votre chat ou votre chien vous lui
mettez un petit un petit micro cheap
dedans et cette puce elle est reliée
alors soit vous avez un truc qui va être
relié par par GPS ça c'est le top du top
mais bon il y a pas trop ce genre de
fond ici donc on est parti sur quelque
chose de beaucoup plus simple c'est
juste une petite puce comme exactement
la même que dans votre chat ou votre
chien mais qui va pouvoir être lu par
des sortes de machines qui vont être
automatiques qu'on va poser sur les
colonies géolesides donc lorsque vous
avez une colonie
telle que celle de bunders Beach par
exemple ou celle de ici de bola lunch
vous avez des routes
que les manchots empruntent tous les
jours pour aller dans la mer et pour
revenir de la mer alors je vais essayer
de vous en trouver une en gros pour
rentrer et pour sortir de l'eau les
manchots empruntent quasiment toujours
la même route il peut y avoir plusieurs
routes par île parce que le nid mais ça
va être toujours plus ou moins les mêmes
et donc ce qu'on va faire dans ces
cas-là c'est qu'on va mettre des
lecteurs de puces électroniques sur ces
routes qui sont empruntées tous les
jours et qui vont permettre de
savoir quel manchot a emprunter quelle
route à quelle heure ils sont rentrés et
sortis de la colonie à quelle heure ils
sont partis pêcher quelle heure ils sont
revenus s'ils sont revenus pas du tout
ou si ils ont décidé ce jour-là de
partir sur une autre colonie et du coup
grâce à ça on va pouvoir savoir si vos
manchots ils sont partis à droite ou à
gauche ou s'ils ont décidé de le
finalement de rester dans cette colonie
là et puis bah voilà c'est tout
c'est une méthode pour nous pour
arriver à suivre les populations et puis
suivre cette fois-ci plus les individus
qui vont qui vont se balader à droite et
à gauche donc ça c'est un des autres
projets
qu'on avait avec là du coup je vois que
c'est soundcock qui a repris le projet
et donc voilà c'est juste des puces
électroniques comme ce que vous avez
dans votre chat ou votre chien tout
simplement vous avez d'autres actions
conservation comme celui de
africaine pingouins
donc pareil en Afrique du Sud pas loin
de la côte mais cette fois-ci un peu
plus alors celui-là il va être
de ce côté là voilà donc là vous avez le
cap ici et puis vous allez porter des du
coup eux ils vont aussi récupérer des
manchots et des oiseaux marins et puis
quand ils sont quand ils sont mauvais
état ils les remettent il irait remettre
en pleine forme et puis après il les
relâche voilà donc les traitements
médicaux et puis ils vont se déplacer
donc vous les appelez si jamais il y a
un problème ils viennent récupérer le
manchot et puis voilà
il s'en occupe donc ça c'est pas mal et
puis il faisait aussi partie du projet
avec Lenny
et il y a un autre truc qui s'est mis en
place dernièrement aussi pour la
protection des manchots et donc ils font
partie c'est la mise en place
deux zones protégées ce qu'ils appellent
des MPa qui sont des Marines donc des
zones marines protégées qui vont
permettre de créer des endroits qui sont
sans intervention humaine pour les
manchots c'est-à-dire qu'en gros d'une
on va pas venir les embêter dans leur
colonie sûr qu'on va pas embêter les
manchots parce que on veut faire des
jolies photos venir les gratouiller
voilà donc il y aura pas de tourisme ou
alors de très loin et il y aura pas non
plus de surpêche dans ces zones là il y
aura pas de pêche du tout d'ailleurs
parce que du coup ça permettra de
conserver le stock de poissons
uniquement pour les manchots et puis bah
pour tout le reste des créatures qui
sont là comme ça voilà on n'est pas trop
en compétition avec eux alors c'est un
pied elles sont très bien sauf qu'elles
sont évidemment un petit peu limité
parce que la zone que vous protéger doit
ne peut pas être trop grande parce que
si vous la faites trop grande ça veut
dire que vous tuez un petit peu tout
votre industrie
de la pisciculture de poissons derrière
parce que
parce que c'est ces gens là aussi ils
ont besoin de manger et ces gens là
aussi ils ont besoin de travailler ils
ont besoin d'aller pêcher pour ça donc
vous pouvez pas non plus décider tout
d'un coup toute la côte est protégée ça
y est plus personne ne pêche c'est pas
possible donc il faut faire avec aussi
les entreprises qui qui vont pêcher donc
vous pouvez mettre en place des zones de
protection mais vous pouvez pas non plus
les faire trop étendues sinon vous tuez
votre industrie derrière
et donc le problème qu'on a c'est que
les poissons ils vont pas se limiter
juste à la zone protégée ils vont aussi
sortir de la zone notamment dans le cas
des sardines on est reparti par exemple
sur le sardines run ici les sardines
elles vont ici la majeure partie de
l'année sauf que elle se balade elle
reste pas juste au même endroit et puis
après pendant l'hiver et ben elle
remonte sur les côtes et elle quitte
complètement les zones protégées les
zones marines protégées qui ont été
mises en place
et là tout le monde a le droit de les
pêcher dans ces cas c'est les zones de
protection marine ça a une certaine
utilité mais l'impact est pas aussi
important que ce qu'on aimerait vraiment
pour que l'espèce se re-développe
survivent sorte de l'extinction
voilà donc ça c'est une autre action qui
est mise en place avec des résultats
plus ou moins positifs on va dire mais
c'est quelque chose qui qui peut entre
autres aider à la programmation des
manchots du Cap donc pour les zones
protégées il y en a eu quelques-unes qui
ont été récemment mises en place en plus
de ce qu'il y avait déjà donc notamment
du côté de port-elisabeth vous avez
toute une zone maintenant qui a été
protégée juste ici
autour de certaines îles qui qui
contiennent des oiseaux marins et
notamment du manchot et ce qui va
peut-être on espère permettre que les
manchots se redéveloppent dans cette
zone là bon voilà c'est un espoir on
n'est pas sûr que ça fonctionne mais on
croise les doigts si vous voulez chaque
action
séparément n'a pas finalement un très
grand impact l'action de juste remettre
des nids sur place sur les îles c'est
bien mais ça va pas régler par exemple
le problème de nourriture maintenant
l'action de mettre en place des MPI donc
les zones de protection marine c'est
bien mais ça va pas régler le problème
déni
et ça règle pas non plus le problème de
la nourriture au complet l'action de
récupérer des petits pour les élever ou
de les sauver quand il y a un problème
ou de les soigner s'ils sont malades
c'est bien aussi mais c'est pareil ça
règle pas le reste des problèmes qui
sont la pollution massive qu'on a tout
autour des côtes le plastique enfin bref
tout ça donc si vous voulez chaque
action
va s'ajouter aux autres et va permettre
une fois que vous avez un tout de de
vraiment progresser vers le résultat que
vous souhaitez vous pouvez pas faire
juste une action et se dire c'est bon on
a sauvé l'espèce ça marchera pas il faut
plusieurs actions en fait pour arriver à
un résultat à peu près correct et
surtout il faut que tout le monde se
mette d'accord pour arriver à aller dans
le même sens parce que si jamais il y en
a qui dit de toute façon moi non je fais
mon petit truc dans mon coin et puis les
autres je m'en fiche ça marchera pas non
plus généralement c'est des actions
concertées qui se font ensemble je vais
pas vous mentir pour le manchot africain
pour l'instant on n'est pas bien parti
alors on essaie de faire ce qu'on peut
mais voilà vu vu les problèmes qu'il est
en train auquel il a à faire face en ce
moment n'est pas top en ce moment le
manchot
ça c'est un truc que je fais jamais
alors j'aime beaucoup gramme
c'est le gars qui est dans la vidéo il
est très sympa il est il connaît très
bien son boulot il est très doué avec
les oiseaux aussi mais par contre ça là
pour moi sinon je m'explique on dit aux
gens tout le temps sur les réseaux
sociaux sur Facebook sur Twitter sur
Instagram importe arrêter les selfies
avec les animaux arrêtez juste ça suffit
c'est pas la peine de vouloir vous
prendre en photo avec un animal mignon
parce que c'est vrai que ça va faire
plus de vues et tout mais derrière il y
a plein d'autres choses qui sont qu'on
ne devrait pas cautionner que du coup
vous cautionnez en prenant cette photo
avec cet animal et que vous encouragez
même c'est-à-dire le trafic d'animaux le
problème de mutilation pour certains
animaux le fait que ces animaux ne sont
pas du tout soignés comme ils le
devraient son prix à leur milieu naturel
alors qu'il ne devrait pas on a tendance
à dire arrêter de de faire de prendre
des photos des amis des animaux mignons
arrêtez de faire de montrer que vous
faites des câlins des animaux mignons
devant la caméra on sait que ça fait
plus de vues on le sait mais c'est pas
le bon comportement à adopter et surtout
c'est pas quelque chose alors dans notre
métier ben oui on a des manchots comme
ça on a des animaux que on touche parce
que tu as pas le choix quand
tu essaies de les nourrir quand tu
essaies dans de les élever bah oui
évidemment tu es au contact de l'animal
mais tu le cabines pas forcément donc ça
pour moi c'est pas c'est pas du tout une
bonne image à montrer en fait voilà donc
ça ça typiquement pour moi c'est c'est
non
bon après c'est je comprends que tu as
envie de récupérer la balle du public et
te dire oui avec un animal mignon ça
marche mieux quand même c'est comme tous
ces chats mignons dans ces vidéos tu
sais c'est pour ramener des viewers
c'est clair mais c'est pas quelque chose
à encourager en fait tu devrais pas
montrer ce genre de comportement sur
caméra c'est pour les gamins
voilà c'est juste que pour moi le
comportement
n'est pas encouragé et c'est pas quelque
chose qu'on devrait montrer vraiment à
la caméra parce que bon oui bah oui
c'est ça si c'est quoi le risque de
causer plus de mal que bien c'est quand
ton productif bah oui donc du coup voilà
déjà on dit aux gens on va arrêter les
selfies avec les animaux ça serait
gentil parce que vous avez certainement
tous entendu les histoires de assez
horrible de bestioles qui sont fait
arracher des dents ou bien enlever les
griffes pour pouvoir être donné après
des touristes qui veulent juste prendre
une photo avec c'est assez triste bon
pour les manchots
pas du tout au moins que on considériez
que voler sous l'eau c'est que nager
c'est une sorte de vol dans l'eau mais
en l'occurrence lui il vole pas du tout
mais du coup moi je connais un manchot
qui a vraiment volé et pas juste sauter
et que planer deux minutes et tomber
dans l'eau
dans le ciel pendant plusieurs heures
c'était dans un dans un aquarium où il y
avait des des manchots du coup ce jour
là comme comme d'habitude il faisait une
présentation pour aller visiteurs où il
montrait le nourrissage des manchots
comme souvent et c'est manchots là étant
suffisamment habitué à l'homme vu qu'il
était en captivité et pas mal d'entre
eux ayant été élevé en captivité donc
elle départ l'homme en l'occurrence bah
ils étaient très familiers et donc en
fait les visiteurs étaient juste à côté
de l'enclos des manchots vous avez juste
un tout petit muret qui séparait les
deux et puis c'était tout mais bon voilà
ils étaient pas méchants ils allaient
pas attaquer les visiteurs il y avait
toujours quelqu'un avec
les visiteurs pour que il y ait pas non
plus de souci qu'ils essaient pas de
toucher les manchots ou quoi donc tout
allait bien ce jour-là une famille
arrive pour voir le déjeuner des
manchots tout se passe très bien la
famille repart enchantée l'aquarium
était formidable les manchots étaient
superbes tout se passe bien à l'aquarium
un peu plus tard on fait le deuxième
nourrissage de la journée parce que
souvent les manchots vous les ont laissé
une à deux fois par jour ça dépend de
l'âge et puis ça dépend aussi si ils ont
mangé le matin ou pas ils peuvent des
fois d'essayer de manger le matin et pas
l'après-midi ou l'après-midi pas le
matin bref ça dépend de l'individu ils
sont un peu difficiles des fois et donc
il regarde pendant le deuxième
nourrissage de la journée il se rendent
compte qu'un des manchot man qu'elle
appelle alors là la panique excusez-moi
où est passé mon manchot il cherche
partout impossible de retrouver le
manchot en question arrive le soir
toujours pas de manchots et là
l'aquarium reçoit un coup de fil à
l'autre bout du fil c'était la mer
c'était la famille qui était venue le
matin qui était absolument paniqué parce
que son enfant en ouvrant son sac elle
avait découvert un manchot dedans
le problème c'est qu'ils étaient pas
tout à côté c'est que eux ils étaient
partis à la plage pour les vacances et
qu'après ils étaient rentrés de vacances
en avion à johannesbur c'est-à-dire que
ça fait à peu près une à deux heures
d'avion quand même c'est pas tout à côté
il s'avère donc qu'en fait c'était
l'enfant de la famille qui ayant décidé
que les manchots ça faisait quand même
de vachement bonne peluches pendant le
nourrissage personne ne le regardant il
avait simplement attrapé l'un des
manchons qui avait devant lui là juste
de l'autre côté du petit muret il
l'avait pris il l'avait mis dans son sac
et puis il était rentré avec et le
manchot ayant été élevés à la main ils
sentaient bien il allait bien il y avait
pas de souci il était dans le sac au
chaud tout allait bien et ben il a pas
fait un bruit
et la famille est redescendue le
lendemain en voiture alors la route en
voiture prend 2 jours quand même donc
ils sont repartis
toute vitesse vers l'aquarium avec le
manchot dans la voiture
pour ramener l'animal elle aquarium si
vous pouvez pas reprendre d'avion tout
de suite j'ai plus possible bref
donc voilà nous avons un manchot qui a
effectivement volé pendant une heure et
demie deux heures dans le ciel
et c'est une histoire vraie donc si vous
allez dans un aquarium n'essayez pas de
mettre des manchots dans vos sacs quand
même voilà ça c'était l'histoire de
manchot
la vraie histoire de manchot merci à
toutes et à tous d'avoir suivi cette
vidéo on se retrouve très bientôt sur
twitch ou sur Youtube pour de nouvelles
aventures avec des plumes
[Musique]